I was joking with you before we started
the interview that when I was running
for president I told the American people
I would come clean about Area 51 and
whatever the government knew about
extraterrestrials so you encountered
unidentified aerial phenomena at various
points during your military career
certainly so after our my first combat
deployment when we came back we upgraded
our Radars from the APG 73 to the 79
radar just a much better radar can see
more things and we started noticing
things that we weren't seeing just
earlier in the day with the other radar
and what we were seeing were just radar
contacts that we weren't expecting they
were typically stationary
0.0 Mach and that's stationary in the
Stream if you will of the air and so
we're not expecting anything to be
stationary up there unless it's Tethered
to the ground and even then it would be
bouncing around
but these would typically be stationary
or when they were not stationary they
travel about 0.6 to 0.8 Mach which is
upwards of about 350 knots any other
circular patterns or race track patterns
or just heading out east over the ocean
eventually we got close enough where all
our sensors inside of our jet they
essentially slew to whatever our radar
is looking at at this time we just
thought they were radar malfunctions not
physical objects that could uh hurt our
aircraft yet sure but eventually we got
close enough with our sensor systems to
actually make out the IR energy the
infrared energy that was coming off of
the the objects and so at this point we
had to respect that you know there was
physically something at that piece of
the sky and to you know avoid it the
best we could
um of course you know there was a
investigatory period where people said
hey let's go take a look with their
eyeballs and and see what we can find
here and now you know I was one of those
people and it was um
it was interesting we would have it on
the radar we would have it on then the
Fleer system that IR system
and all that's getting pumped into our
visor and tracked to our eyeballs and
telling us exactly where to look and we
do this type of merging exercise quite
often where we fly up to something we
assess its characteristics its weapons
load out and we begin a dog fight with
it
um in this case we would come up to that
merge and all our sensors would show us
where to look but then we couldn't see
the objects we turned back around and
they would still be there on the radar
and on the flear
and that was kind of a status quo for a
while until we almost hit one of the
objects at the entrance to our working
areas two aircraft from my Squadron were
entering the working areas
um side by side and at a very particular
altitude and GPS location is where we
enter those working areas and one of
these objects went right between the two
aircraft uh and the lead aircraft was
able to actually gain tally of it and he
described it as a black Cube inside of a
clear sphere
about five to fifteen feet in diameter
when you say gain tally of it you
actually saw it with his own eyes
correct with his own eyeballs and to my
knowledge that was the first time we had
seen uh one of these objects with their
own eyes there's a black Cube within a
clear sphere and the tips of the cube
best we could assess at that point were
touching inside that clear sphere so
you're probably
friends with the other Pilots when when
you got back and you were saying hey
what did you see and he described this
you guys must have been eager to hear
more or flipping out or something along
those lines
we were moving along a progression right
we went from radar errors to something
physical but not knowing what they were
but when we saw it physically like that
our first thought you know we were never
all about UFOs or or uaps as they're
called now that really never entered
into our conscience other than something
to laugh at
um so we always thought there was a very
pragmatic explanation if we just had
enough information
um and at this point when we physically
saw it like I said as that Cube we
assumed that some this must have been
some kind of strange classified program
or drone program that must have gotten
too big for its britches and essentially
has been operating in a place that they
should have been perhaps by accident
perhaps not but either way something had
to be done and due to the nature of this
near mid-air uh I mean we were obligated
to file a Aviation safety report due to
the close proximity and that's what we
did we started filing them within the
aviation safety hazard reporting system
and that was again status quo for the
time being we essentially just disarmed
them we tried to avoid them if they were
in our working areas which they're out
there pretty much every day in some
capacity we would just you know Flex to
a different area and do our best to
avoid them you so you follow the report
but it sounds like it's pretty much
common knowledge among Pilots that hey
there are these things out there they're
going to hit your radar in a particular
way
they seem like actual objects like if
you get close to your instruments I'll
start saying hey the thing's there and
you want to try and avoid them because
if you hit one no one knows what happens
we would assume it would be I mean
catastrophic to the aircraft I mean
based off of what we are seeing there's
no question in our mind that you know
this would result in loss of aircraft
like if we hit anything of that size out
there
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you're
really every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you